person of the year persons
of the year person of the year joe biden
kamala harris were you celebrating when
you saw that
i'm going to shock you even though you
know obviously i was very emotional
yesterday
breaking news biden is going to be the
president electoral college uh
officially put him in office but you
know what i'm going to shock you i do
not think that joe biden and kamala
harris
should be people of the year you know
these are where's the list people excuse
me
persons over here people is a bad word
now
oh you got to be careful with people you
can't say people you say
person of the year persons please don't
offend our audience go go ahead the time
time persons of the year they were the
candidates persons
person people singular person even
though it's two
okay time knows better english than you
and i do so it's time said
person of the year for two people so
tell us
the four candidates or were uh biden and
kamala harris or biden
trump um the racial justice movement and
then
frontline healthcare workers coupled
with anthony fauci i know we're not
about to say people or persons in my
opinion
the winner should be the frontline
healthcare workers are you freaking
kidding me if in a year of covid uh
they're literally giving up their lives
and and the death that they see on a
daily basis 300 000 deaths
in the united states over a million
deaths worldwide
the the health care workers uh should
win uh the person of the year people of
the year
crew of the year whatever you want to
call them they should be putting
pictures of doctors nurse nurses health
care workers
on the cover of time not biden and
kamala harris not trump
not fouchy uh not social justice
movement the healthcare workers
time still has a magazine
congratulations that that's right up
time person of the year
is right up there with the good
housekeeping seal of approval
okay who gives a crap you're so
irrelevant time you suck
basically hey let's just look at this
she called him a racist
this year to his face a racist
he picks her because he has to this guy
can't even play with his poodle without
breaking half the bones in his body
okay the photos is horrible i mean what
is that even a photo
they look like they're dying both of
them it looks like you're at a funeral
for both of them
what a joke it's like it'd be like
playboy naming nancy pelosi
playmate of the year what did what did
joe biden do to you what did a democrat
do to you
something must have happened in your
life that was a strict commentary that's
all i'm just saying something must have
happened for you to get this angry about
something no man it's like time who are
you
you're irrelevant i mean they came out
with their shopping list the
shopping guide they said go buy a new
walkman when they um
when they had trump in 2016 as time
person of the year what did you
deserve so you liked it then you defied
history you liked it the time was worth
it back then it meant something forgot
it was four years ago how it is
nice tom uh seriously time sucks who are
they
i think i think this happens every year
and this is exactly what they like
to do they like to pick somebody that's
going to piss you off because it's going
to bring more eyeballs and more people
talking about it and you
you know mark bennehoff owns them now by
the way you know the the founder of
salesforce just who owns time magazine
i don't know if you knew that yes he
bought him for like what did he buy for
i think he bought it for 351 million or
some number like that can you pull it up
mark benihoff buys time magazine benny
hoff
uh time magazine um
benny hoff time magazine let's see what
he paid for it
uh what did he pay for that's what i
want to know under 50 million probably
no no he paid he paid a good amount for
it uh 100
000 90 that's nothing
ah that just pisses me off that's
nothing so
oh my gosh mark benny off let's just
give a shout out to him real quick
obviously
business person of the year
unquestionably was elon musk
well according to fortune magazine yeah
i think many people would
agree on that and then bezos richest man
in the world um
and i'm sure we'll touch on even gates
in the in this episode but mark benioff
salesforce he just acquired slack kai
probably has something that he would
want to add about i think he's
was he called deal maker of the year
this guy's an absolute stud this guy
mark benioff
um kai what what what did we talk about
um no he said he took over from
larry allison on the most acquisitions
and acquired anything
for larry ellison yeah yeah he was a
former they just bought slack
yeah the guy he knows what's up
bennehoff yeah yeah benefit worked for
uh
ellison yeah i think so at oracle he was
a vice president
executive he is not a household name
that just tells you right there the
power of who you work for
let me tell you what that tells you
right that tells you the power of who
you work for
what what habits and things you pick up
from working for somebody like that of
course you think benihalf would have
been
if he hadn't had a person like that to
shadow what a great example of what it
means to shadow somebody
that's a beautiful story right there to
be able to work with someone like that
and plus it feels like he's competing
with them trying to outdo them but you
know what i disagree with one thing i
don't think time is that forward
thinking where they put them on the
cover
to engage i think they're that woke i
really do okay
yeah i mean to me i um i just kind of
see it i'm like yeah i guess they have
to announce those two as time magazine
person of the year i mean who else you
gonna announce realistically who else
fauci would have been the guy would it
be
they've done in the past uh like in 20
uh they've done multiple people is what
i'm saying a couple years ago i think in
2010
you know who was the time person of the
year you
not you pbd but us you the the people
the people
were we were the time people of the
years like oh damn i'm a time person
i might put that on my resume i was time
person of the year in 2010
me and all seven billion of us on this
planet eight billion
but um 2016 was trump
i i kind of agree with tom that like who
gives a [ __ ] and i also agree
um it is important because people do
talk about this kind of stuff
and lastly i think they are looking to
stir up controversy when they put on a
bite and a comment but they did get
people
we're talking about it now if it was the
healthcare workers which i think
should have been the time people of the
year would be like if you're listening
to this who do you think should have
been the time management obviously we
know our audience loves biden so
obviously they
have no idea what they're going to say
what do you think they're we have a bad
audience who do you think should be that
first of all no one's going to say
trump's the time end of the year i mean
it's yeah if you're going to say
it's just the time there's going to be a
lot of people i'm sure they're going to
what i'm trying to say is there's going
to be some that are going to say
somebody
[Music]